you hear a lot of different stories
about all these mob families when you've
got five different families out there
like New York you run into problems
you've been a tough guy since you were a
kid coming up when I grew up my father
was a real tough guy it was a driver a
wheelman and a killer and a killer of
course it bother me I think about the
faces all the time
how do you process it as it happened
when you're sleep and done it's over
with there's nothing I could do I can't
you can't bring him back he's then clean
your dirty laundry now I'd have fall out
of a tree I've heard that term used too
many times if you've seen the movie
Casino the guys had the Vice and come on
I didn't do that well let's say Tony
doesn't roll when you use that word
that's like snitching is the same thing
exactly got it we got a big robbery it
was a bank we didn't count the money as
we were taking it out with Trude in
duffle bags I was 18 years old I had
never seen that much money in my life
then the bad news came that's when I
really learned about the Chicago Outfit
here regardless of what you Aaron this
is true story
[Music]
so today we have another former mafia
member from Chicago that moved to Vegas
to work with Tony Spilotro Frank
Cullotta is his name and if you don't
know Frank Cullotta is Frank Cullotta if
you've seen a movie Casino Frank Vincent
played the role of Frank Marino which is
really Frank Cullotta and he was running
with Joe Pesci who played Nicky Santoro
which in real life it's really the story
of Tony's pilâtre and there's a lot of
different things we're gonna talk about
today you know a lot of different
stories a lot of different backgrounds
the difference between the New York
outfits versus Chicago and a bunch of
other topics so with that being said
Frank Cullotta Frank thank you so much
for being a guest here on value tainment
appreciate you for coming out so so
Frank you know you you hear a lot of
different stories about all these mob
families New York Chicago all these
different outfits what was the biggest
different culturally with Chicago mob
family versus the ones in New York you
know I don't know how to answer that
question to be true fortune we're a
bunch of Italian people if that's what
you're looking for and we stuck together
we had values principles we live by and
we had one boss we didn't answer
directly to the bus we had several under
bosses that we answered though he was
far far in a distance you know but we
know where the messages were coming from
so you think so that's one of the things
I wanted to touch up on so New York had
five bosses well lucky kind of divided
everybody up and everybody went through
the five bosses and then they would come
kind of work together
Chicago was under one boss what do you
think was it different and the benefit
of having one versus seven five one boss
one leader let's say it's not as
confusing for sure when you got five
different families out there like New
York had you run it the problems
everybody's got different things
different ther thirties in Chicago
there's one boss you know what he wanted
he had different made men around him
they recalled main men and these guys
had territories so if you work for one
and he's made men you
he was getting the orders from the
underboss of the head guy at that time
was Paul Ricca mm-hmm
he was the boss in Chicago from 1962 to
1970 though they called him Paul the
waiter Ricca Ricardo went into
retirement but as soon as Rico went back
to jail or died I'm sorry
then our Carlo takes over temporarily
and then he puts somebody else to
control things and at that time they use
the guy by the name of Jack Cerrone and
then when Jack went the jelly I mean he
could go in and add then he is Joey
ayyappa another boss and Joey ayyappa
goes all the way back to Al Capone isn't
Joe we all said the one that ended up
putting the hit on spilatro because he
was too concerned about what's taking
place here in Chicago here in New Vegas
joy you posed in penitentiary at the
time for for the Las Vegas skin if he
was out Tony would have probably never
got murdered the guy that put the hit
ant on his flight row and his brother
Michael was named Joe ferry Ola we
should call him John the gold white but
why did he see Julia you could did a lot
of articles talk about the fact that
Joey put the hit show up was in jail he
was very close to Tony very close to
Tony and that's one of the reasons Tony
wood became the guy he was because of
Joey ayyappa the only thing I believe
that Joey iopa was thinking about at
that time was getting out of jail I mean
he's an old man they put him in jail got
it got it so he was a boss in jail so
okay so let's go back before we talk
about some of the Vegas stuff you know
when I read a lot of stuff on you is
Frank I mean it's you been a tough guy
since you were a kid coming up it's it's
what I hear about so coming up in the
streets of Chicago who were you in the
streets of Chicago quick like if I knew
you had 12 13 14 years old who was Frank
just the tough guy that didn't take
orders well from people that had a sort
of a complex about born thick glasses at
the family's throat thick glasses
so I had a complex overnight famous in a
New York second you know and a lot of
people would say he's the tough he's a
tough guy don't mess with him referring
to me I never heard that but later on in
years I used to hear all them stories so
in who were your parents what did your
mom do my father was killed when I was
eight years old in an automobile
accident he was being pursued by the
police
my mother was a wonderful lady she was a
housewife took care of us she was eight
months pregnant with my brother at the
time my father was killed in his
automobile accident and I had a sister
an older sister five years older than me
my mother did the best she could do she
was left a little money but you know the
money runs out so yeah she never works
so she had a fine a job and she was good
she never wanted me to be the way I
turned out she never wanted you to know
that she would never take no money
Frank was that in your environment I
don't Lordan know what we're was the mob
and the Mafia around you at all or no
listen when I grew up my father was a
real tough guy had he was a legendary
guy everybody know about Joe Collider
that was his name sighs they heard his
stories about my father he never want to
be connected to the Chicago Outfit
although he did things for him he just
never wanted to be connected because he
didn't want anybody telling him how to
live his life as I was
see that's the things I learned I didn't
I sort of wanted to be like him he was a
driver a wheelman and a killer and a
killer I am he was a killer from these
stars there and of course he's not gonna
tell me this his friends and relatives
not my mom and my mother relatives maybe
distance cousins
so I idolized them but he isn't what
drove me to be the person I turned out
to be I hung it in a bird were I used to
see all these old-time
smoking cigars had the fedoras and their
ad trenchcoat stop Coons nice cars never
working beautiful woman around him I
thought maybe this was the kind of way I
wanted to go to be like them but I don't
want to be connected I don't want to be
a gangster what age did you see that and
what age did you start seeing the fedora
you're not at 14 at 14 15 and your and
your dad died when you were 8 correct
and when you were 8 you had a brother
that was coming he said your sister's
five years older than you that's correct
and so let me ask you what impact did it
have when you heard the story you're
eight years old you hear this story mom
somebody tells you dad just got into an
accident cops were chasing him how what
kind of an impact it because this is a
man you idolized what did that do to you
it hurt me to lose my father of course
sure trouble me deeply really bothered
me the impact it had was not as far as
getting even with the police or anything
like that none of that I admired him my
mother always told me don't believe all
the stories you hear but I hired my
father and I course I believe them
stories so it had a big impact on my
life I thought about it years later and
I think it sent me in a direction I went
did it produce any rage at all or no was
there anything like you know because it
is I'm gonna want to be like my dad
even more than I wanted before well I
did see a lot of rage in my father I
seen a lot of rage in my father my
mother was never struck by my father he
verbally screamed at or all the tankers
he was a very jealous man my mother was
a very attractive woman a very good
woman but my father was a very insecure
man and he scream at her he was
particular about the furniture I mean
and as a kid the sticks in your my lane
is developed when you're sick yeah of
course I'm 8 years old so but I never
done that things see that as far as
hollering at females as I got older
because I think I learned from that
some people go the opposite direction
interesting but I learned from that but
I still love my filer
and I never seen him stealing I just
heard stories about him stealing and
killing people and stuff like that and
that was fashionable done for people to
talk about stuff like that and that's
that was probably sent me on my way got
it so it was a source of you know maybe
inspiration but also at the same time a
way of a life so you're 14 years old
you've seen these fedoras you're seeing
this lifestyle you're kind of a kid that
you don't want people to push you around
and tell you what to do you're build a
little bit of a reputation what was the
first experience on how you started
getting close to the family the Chicago
Outfit yes that family well of course I
knew they were around all the time and
you'd hear stories about them and then
you see these individuals and you would
start a Meyer in them and then my friend
that I start hanging with at the time we
were shining shoes together it's a known
story it's in one of my books his name
was Tony splotch oh and he was a tough
street kid he had five brothers and we
got a confrontation you a Tony oh yeah
and shiny shoes different territory and
then we come to find out that his father
and my father were good friends from the
old neighborhood let's say and we became
friends Tony and I it's something like
you would see in a movie but it's true
and we realized that we were gonna be
friends the rest of our life which we
were and we fought together we stole
together we beat up people together you
fought together or you fought - you
fought other people other people you
never fought each other there was with
his father's reputation like your father
no his father his name was Patsy his
father was a hard-working man he owned
the restaurant and the neighborhood the
old neighborhood grand and Acton and he
was famous for his meatball sandwiches
the reason being that my father and him
his father got
I launched the well my father used to go
in there everybody liked Patsy one day
Patsy told my father he says the black
can't I don't know if you people are
aware with the black can is there a
bunch of grease balls that first came
here many many years ago before there
was a syndicate holiday and aints the
muscle their own cane meaning all the
immigrants from Italy take money from
him so they were putting a muscle on
Tony slide shows father Patsy they go
running to take money from so when they
told Joey told my father say Joe
he said buddies grease balls are driving
me crazy he's they come here once a week
if ain't got the money they're
threatened to me in this and that's my
father's what that a comer and he told
him my father says I'll be here next
Thursday or whatever there was
so these couple of grease balls come in
there they couldn't speak English you
know it says I've what I call grease
balls what yours is like 40 oh yeah I
was I don't I wasn't even in existence
though that's what I'm asking so it's
prior to your existence like you're not
born yeah I wasn't even born yet so they
went in there and my father was in the
back room with another couple guys and
they start threatening Patsy splat Joe
my father and the other guys come out of
the back room and kill these guys took
him and dumped them somewhere I don't
know but kill him and dump them two guys
yeah two guys okay
from there it went a little further then
they went in got the leader bad guy and
they caught him in a motel room he went
on to run him and his wife and they
caught him in a motel room with his wife
they didn't kill the wife they killed
him in bed and that ended the black hand
in Chicago that ended it here regardless
of what you arid this is true story that
ended then the Chicago Outfit came about
all right Capone and so on then it start
come
about and my father was the recognized
individual and he didn't want to be part
of any kind of an organization what was
his reasoning for that because we were
all Italians what are you want to bother
your own kind for hardworking people
that are selling fruit and vegetable on
the street and you come her from the
same country these people come from and
you want to humiliate them and take
their money do like they do say he's got
Manny to protecting them got it
interesting so so then us pilâtre start
doing things you guys are fighting
people you're doing all this other stuff
together and he also had a reputation
said he five brothers and then you
worked and when did when did the money
making a process start for you when you
guys start making some real money well
we were making money you know it doing
they call it the bank route you know
this was later on but what happened was
Tony how it's just the tummy he say
Frankie one day I'm gonna be a boss in
the outfit this is his words and you
hear this all the time how old was he
when he told he does we're not 16 years
old Wow and I tell him I don't want to
be involved with them people you know I
want to do what I'm doing with Robin
whatever Robin would other guys and he
said well when I become a boss I'm gonna
make him my right-hand man I used to
thank you don't but I don't want to be
involved Connie and aces okay okay okay
and were 18 years old and one of my
books don't he come a guy I mean he said
we got a big robbery I want to include
you in Anna and Richie
Richard Garmin Vicky garment they call
it he was the guy that I brought around
it was a thief he says we're gonna go
with three other guys you don't know I
said I never robbed with strangers he
said sir I know these guys they're from
grain and actin meaning the neighborhood
I was born and raised then so he went
down there and we met the three
individuals one of the guys became our
boss in later years his name was Joe
Lombardo
they call him Joey to clone very phase
in jail now doing that your life so we
went and we met these three
individuals and then we drove all of us
the Indiana it was a bank and I thought
we could rob a bank in Illinois why
don't we got to go to Indiana days we're
gonna Rob the safety deposit boxes in
the bank in the vault
so we cased it out we cased it off for a
couple weeks it was a very difficult
robbery very time-consuming because we
had to go that a building next door to
basement your double foundation and the
into the Bynum in a bank and go true to
Florida bank and go into the vault just
like you would see in movies we've done
it then with tools that weren't as
modern as they are today and we got in
there we didn't count the money as we
were taken and I would shoot in duffle
bags we got back to Chicago of course
there was two cars I don't want to go to
your whole thing it'd take forever today
about it we got to Chicago we counted
the money and a bed we in this guy's
place one of the guys that was with us
it was an a full-sized bed the money was
like a foot I covered the whole bed all
denominations and jewelry I was 18 years
old I had never seen that much money in
my life 750,000 cash and it was like I
didn't know we didn't know the value to
jewelry there was like a million in
jewelry and I thought well I'm rich I'm
a millionaire and we all thought that
then the bad news came that's when I
really learned about the Chicago Outfit
Joe Lombardo says you know I'm I worked
for the bosses I run crap games dice
games he's we got a kick in 20% I saying
given nobody [ __ ] Tony says Frankie we
got it he says they'll kill us we won't
be able to spend the money they say
giving it them no money why should I
give them no money I said we rob the
place they don't know about it
he's real joy he's gonna have to tell
him he says you got we got to give it
them so I sorry if that's through it one
of the guys they want to give it up
I don't know whatever happened to him I
never seen him again after that really I
never seen him I know that I got my 20
person I know that I got my money the
jewellery we wind up keeping the money
out of that now Jana you know you and
jeweler if it's worth the Civ estimated
value five million dollars you're
luckier I end up with 25 percent right
yeah so how just to get it is all right
so I wind up with like 50,000 I'm 18
years old
fifty thousand seven hundred fifty
thousand dollar robbery but still it's a
lot of money in 1956 that's a lot of you
know yeah so I was you know happy to get
it and and that's when I learned about
what they should get and then I learned
again that I had to give 20 percent I
always knew it but I mean another big
robbery the first Brinks truck robbery
in Chicago history I done with five
other guys an armored car and we wind up
with 360 some thousand dollars and then
all of a sudden we had to give another
20 force up to the outfit and I told
pops peanuts pants go he was like one of
our guys that put the scar together is
we gonna give that the guys in Cicero
20% I smiled on these guys they're
making money they ain't doing [ __ ] sorry
to keep the money in my house until the
two guys coming
picked it up they're 20% they brought it
to the boss so that's the way it goes in
Chicago you know if you make a large
score you got a kick in 20% what a
benefit you get for that what do you get
a return for that protection but
actually what you wanted though you know
I mean you just can't kill people you
know if you got a scar that's big you
going ask amazed this place connected if
it is and let me know and don't they you
know go ahead and do it of course by
doing that you're letting them know what
you're doing you know the outfit then
you got to kick it in but if it's a
small robbery you know you know you want
to do you want to be a bookmaker and as
I said previously I think I thought
that's where the biggest source of
income came in Chicago was illegal
gambling not drugs
or gambling who was the first that got
into drugs or no one ever got into drugs
yeah it's pretty strange but I don't
know if he's ever heard they call him
mad Sam DiStefano
he was the juice man he started out with
a hundred fifty thousand on a loan from
Paul Ricca he met him in jail and he
said I'll marry you borrow me a hundred
twenty thousand and I'm making a million
a year and he that mmm
so when he set him up when he gave him
that money and set him up they needed to
have somebody with this Sam because he
was nuts the same mad Sam was nuts I
mean really a psychopath killer
so they put Tony splashier with him and
Sam's brother Mario Sam was so bad he
killed his own brother he did or he will
he would vision younger brother killed
Sam killed his own brother
for what reasons drugs he was stealing
drugs
Sam got into the drug business I'm not
varying away from this he wasn't a made
man he was making him over a million
dollars a year for the outfit so they
protected their investment with him now
they knew that he got into the drug
business but they kept their distance
because then it went that it's a
terrible thing to be involved in in
Illinois but yet they got the money in
other words if he the prophet he would
given them profit you know so much I
don't know what it was I can't I usually
tie it and that's when I found out that
they were dealing these drugs true Sam
only Sam at the time and then after a
while the door opened a little bit you
know a little bit more but the bet big
boss says it was more like bootlegging
going back to the bootlegging hey
because there's a lot of money in drugs
but stole illegal gambling was more
money more money in illegal gambling
than draw ran back time thought these
guys are all multimillionaires from from
alcohol to bootlegging days you know let
me ask you frame what is the
relationship at that time between the
Chicago Outfit in New York and I know
there was some stuff in Milwaukee and
Florida and some of this other stuff but
mainly Chicago knew you
how did you guys view each other how did
the families look at each other we got
along ok that was their business
Chicago is our business I don't believe
that we ever need I don't know if
anything I needed anybody from New York
to help us or I know Tony hung around
with a couple guys from New York and
they were pretty nice guys what he done
with him I don't know I know there was
one guy des was sent from New York he
was a young guy he was sent there
because they killed his father his
father's name was Louis I believe the
sons name we call him Louie to mooch
when they whacked his father his father
was a hit man in New York the New York
sent the son to Chicago with us because
he was like wanting to get even for his
father getting killed so they send the
son to Chicago I never did like the guy
as I was growing up I can't stand them
he was one of the guys involved in Tony
splotches murder 2 in Vegas you know in
Chicago that's where they killed Tony
Wow
he was one of the guys involved in the
murder and Tony was his boss interesting
so did he end up getting even with
anybody in New York or know who much he
never got it on yeah yeah when he got to
Chicago he was told you could open up
these jukeboxes and these pinball
machines pick a territory you know you
got to kick it in so the kid was making
a lot of money farm so Frank was the the
families are still you know the money
eventually is going back to Naples and
come back to Sicily right doesn't matter
if it's Chicago or New York I don't
think Chicago money goes back to Chicago
money never went to Sicily as far as I
could tell you know why now what was the
difference between why they were running
nothing over there may have done it in
New York but there weren't run on in
Chicago so you guys didn't go to the
voting every four or five years they you
they were vote when you would go and
vote in the family in Sicily there was
no one from Chicago his party not that I
know of interesting I can honestly tell
you that not that I know of not that you
know from circa okay I mean I would have
heard I
think I would have heard yeah because I
was connected to all the big guys I
should have heard I never heard it maybe
it was that secret that I should know
this pilâtre go to Sicily I don't know
enables no no not a lot or no you never
heard him I don't know he never one or
you never he know the furthest place
everyone was like Paris the UK and was
for jewelry robberies jewel robbery
right got it interesting so when does
witness pilâtre become a boss what age I
he really got involved when he was 18
and I believe in that I'm trying to
think of the year when he became a made
man I think it was in 1970 and between
74 and 77 so I'm not quite sure
mid-thirties
well he was born in May and I was born
in December so we're not that much of a
difference in age 78 both of you born in
38 yeah okay got it
so so he becomes a made man and at this
point what are you guys doing together
you're still running together I was in
an anti jell I was in and out of jail I
got out of jail in 1974 I went in in
1968 for a robbery I didn't commit true
story
I got framed by the government don't say
they can't anybody could frame you there
were just so mad at me because I was
beating all these cases they told me
we'll get you they framed me and I said
you framed me
that's the way it goes I got 15 years
then a lot of things happened a couple
of other people rolled became government
informants and what all these cases they
start testifying me on about the Brinks
truck when I read this that I wound up
with 36 years but they combined all the
years the highest sense they run up to
currently turned out to be 15 years on
the bump case the case that in every
chain said that state and federal time
15 or six and the 15 I did state time I
did four years they paroled me got it to
a federal detainer total time you've
been in how many or six years Oh total
time 12 years you did another six why
not yeah two years they're here there
anything for murder or no nothing was
ever for murder but you obviously you've
committed many yes say that yeah not
many I've committed murder do you know
the number like a two directly to
indirectly to directly to indirectly
death does that at all cost a very
famous one was a very famous one they
called it the M&M murders is this the
one with Jerry no it's the wrong with
Billy McCarthy and Jimmy moralia Jerry
you thought about Jerry Lisner I'm Tom i
Jerry listen that's a different one that
wasn't as famous as the Amana if you've
seen the movie Casino the guys had in
the Vice mm-hmm that was the M&M murders
Oh make me a bad guy come on that's a
pretty tough scene to watch in real life
as that was jammed down in the Vice face
forward down wasn't up I didn't do that
but you were there yeah well let's say
Tony done it interesting so so here's a
question for you I was in the military
and in the military you know you talk to
Special Forces you know Delta you talk
to a lot of these guys eventually it
becomes part of your job where you don't
necessarily look at it as I did
something and I killed this person all
right how was it for you as a first
someone had happened like was it just
kind of like this is my job that's what
I'm supposed to do it was was there a
part of it where you afterwards felt
guilty you thought about the family the
kids people them up or no cold here's
what my job is I'm doing it I'm good to
go
well I didn't look at that as a job I
looked at it as an order that I received
I knew there was you don't get no
paycheck for killing nobody
you know I'm like and there was you know
you get money you know you don't get a
page you get stripes though yeah I guess
you could call it stripes or a notch I
don't know I never thought of it that
way myself I thought of it was if they
come to you and they tell you Frankie or
Pete I want you to kill Pete over to her
Harry
you don't ask why they wouldn't come to
you if they didn't think you would do it
if you say no I don't want to do it
you're gonna die mm-hmm so they come to
you because they know you would do it
for them that's that's a very common
when you ask people who have killed
whether it's military or you ask
gangsters you know I mean in the middle
at there yes it's it's very much more I
don't feel guilty because it's an order
I don't really do it somebody told me to
do it when I try to tell people and
people search like the military
how could you disgrace their military
I'm not disgracing our military but
that's the way you would take it as an
order from up above a lieutenant or
sergeant it ever like did it ever haunt
you at all with the decisions and what
you did did it ever like middle the
night you're like [ __ ] I really did know
it bothered me I didn't I mean it's not
something you relish on doing but after
I rolled and seen the light let's say of
course it bothered me interesting and I
I think about it I think about the faces
all the time do you really yeah till
today oh yeah I could picture their
faces like right now looking at you how
do you process it like how does it
happen when you're safe and done it's
over what there's nothing I could do I
can't you can't bring them back once
it's done am i sorry for my sense you
bet I am
you bet I am interesting so so let me
ask you so at this point you're in
Chicago you're doing what you're doing
at what point did you make your way out
to Vegas I had several businesses going
at the time in Chicago so brown in 1978
or the early part of 1979 I had a disco
and I just got rid of it and Joe
Lombardo I remember I mentioned his name
earlier yes we call him Joe you didn't
call him Joe a client does face you
could kill so Joey comes in my place and
he shakes my auntie's - congratulations
and I thought he was congratulating me
because we saw I sold a giant and I said
yeah he said I got another stuff I got
to do in life
he's what he's talking about you're
moving to Vegas next week and I looked
at and I said well I got some moving to
Vegas the reason why I knew what he was
stalking
but because prior to that Tony had asked
me Tony swatch oh four or five times to
move to Vegas with him to be his backup
guy what's he already in Vegas or he was
in Vegas since 1972
oh so way before you like seven years
before don't forget I was a gel I didn't
get out to that's running for years yeah
that's right got it
so I said alright I guess I'm moving to
Vegas but I can't do it in a week Joe
phases dude in his fastest amount of
time you can so like in a couple weeks
three weeks I did move to Vegas and
that's when I knew that where my
functions were gonna be in Vegas did I
know there was a skim going on yet did I
know I was going on at that time no I
didn't want to know but I did find out
of course they didn't why don't know
that's one more person that knows that's
one more person they can name so what I
knew what I had to do I had to protect
the hotels that the Chicago Outfit
control there were four hotels was the
Stardust
the Fremont the Hacienda and the marina
for properties that we control you know
in other words they had a guy they put
him in there his name was Ellen Glick it
was one of these rich real estate
developers or whatever he was I didn't
know the guy personally I just know who
he was and left he was in there he
thought he was going to be in there to
manage the gambling part of it but being
they had a record he couldn't do that so
they made him a charge of entertainment
but he still was over to oversee the
skim left he was Lefty
he never watched him take it out he
didn't know he just received the money
as they say in my tour he received the
money once a week and then he would drop
it off and if you've seen the movie
Casino mm-hmm that's the direction it
went got it and what what ways did you
make money here pardon me what ways did
you make money here obviously there's a
lot of different ways they make money
there were several ways when I came out
Tony told me that what my functions were
gonna be to make sure nobody cheated
in these hotels the shakedown bookmakers
the guys that were doing the illegal
bookmaking get them for 20% or more and
I said well these guys are connected to
guys in different cities don't worry
about it he says just do it
aces and you'll see what happens so I
send my guys out no before that I told
Tony these guys gotta earn a living
if we must at least bookmakers you're
getting the money they ain't gonna do it
for naught mmm he said tell him they
could steal out or they could do
whatever they want in Vegas they could
what steal Rob from you from them from
öhlins businesses oh I see which was
unknown at the time I said you sure you
got the okay from Chicago because of
what's going on on her you know with us
and the money in the casino he says it's
all taken care of your guys could do
what they wanted though I says okay so I
told my guys and man it was like opening
up a can of worms so we got that name to
hole-in-the-wall gang yeah so I did my
little thing catching cheaters and
hotels Muslim bookmakers sending that
money back to Tony but what I found out
and doing that the first guy was from
Boston I went to put the muscle on my
son Larry Neumann he worked for me
mm-hmm
he was a killing machine this guy he
also came here from Chicago yes I met
him in prison he was doing honor 25
years for a triple murder you only did
11 years
where is he originally from some suburb
in Chicago in Chicago
yeah okay got it it was a crazy guy
crazy crazier than Sam Mad Men or
whatever sicker I should say sick yeah
oh yeah he was a sick man hmm
he would kill anybody he would do things
to people that is disgusting hey I mean
if you should kill somebody shoot him he
would he'd chop him up and everything
else sick man so anyway I told Tony this
and Tony said tell your guys they could
do this they could do that knowledge I
say he said pieces
then he told me sorry back off of his
guy from Boston I said why is he paying
up he said yeah he said talk to his
bosses in Boston and they told me
alright Tony look out for my guy and
we'll cut you in and my reaction see see
what the Xena game he was my aunt he
tell them I'll protect your guy
they tell Tony from other cities New
York everywhere estate will take care of
you Tony make sure that nobody muscles
our bookmaker and that's what happened
so we used to go out do this farm which
opened up the door for my gain you know
my crew what's the biggest hit you guys
had here the biggest one biggest hit
biggest jewelry I know you guys a lot of
different things a lot of different
things you know a couple hundred
thousand in jewelry maybe eighty
thousand in cash you know but it was
plentiful in other words at that time
nobody people didn't report to the
government their tips and they keep this
stuff in-house I mean I opened up a
restaurant at tree days out there you
know it's all that we did was
burglarized tree houses here yeah it was
all cash and you had a restaurant open
it up with the cash did you do anything
with Johnny Russo at all or no I know
Johnny rose so he wasn't a movie to
Godfather he wasn't a movie generous is
a good cash
I thought Johnny resort thing I said
Johnny you know what you are you're the
guys that portray me I'm the real thing
he's I know I know he's a good guy
Johnny I was playing with him what year
was that how long ago was that 78 79
Gianni was connected to Costello though
Johnny years ago he had a relationship
whenever he probably had a relationship
well yeah but he know us guys yeah he
had a nightclub here I think for like
yeah it was a Joe and he had it he
killed somebody there yeah yeah I lived
at the Marie Antoinette when I first
moved out her and he's the date a woman
in that bowling the an Warwick mm-hmm
you say so I see him every day in
sightseer why'd you live there was it
intentional we kind of like I had those
in there
okay so there's
move daughter got it then I was thought
I can't live there no more but it oh
here's the situation cuz who I am
the cops were coming they're constantly
cops
yeah great my place all the time
interesting interesting so let me ask
you I mean obviously this thing's going
you're doing what you're doing
at what point that things turn for you
at what point did things turn with you
and Tony I know FBI got involved they
started kind of watching what you guys
were doing that never bother me with the
FBI being involved as a matter of fact
they know it was like a security blanket
you know who's gonna hit us who's gonna
kill us with these Skype watching us all
day long what bothered me as Tony was
never contributing to our cases like
financially it wasn't Tony's attorney
Oscar Goodman that ended up being your
attorney as well that he represented you
right he was a he was a coal attorney
you know our attorney yeah john mama was
my attorney he was an adviser got it
that's all he did how was your
relationship with Oscar it was good at
the time but Oscar got mad at me after I
rolled and that's his business but I
made a statement he's through a Rolex
watch and it was a it was a knockoff it
was a phony so one day when I was going
to court I didn't have a tie so Tony
said you got a VAT asker said where's
your tie I don't work ties they were
sport jackets you know so Tony took his
tie off I said I don't make maths so
Oscar says I'll make it for you so Oscar
made than that and as he's making a man
I'm looking at his watch I see that a
phony Rolex and he's because I don't
want guys like you to rock me so I said
that and went all over the error you
know after I rolled so it embarrassed
them so then he said the guy don't even
that I'm making that out of stay who
cares
and what is this in the 70s is the 70s
86 0 7 he was in the seventies eighties
there early have you guys reconnected at
all since dusk
not at all there's no need to there's no
need to he stays away from me well we
were doing the movie he was anisette is
to see me then come near me who would
ask you the questions on the movie who
was asking you questions I work right
when Martin Scorsese
oh you work directly with I sat in a
chair right next stone so they were
asked what questions were they asking
you how would he use that type of gun is
this the way you shoot somebody that's
specifically a break a hole in the wall
whatever we did you know in real life he
asked me so anything you've seen in that
movie was directions for me Murray said
right next to me and how was Pesci
asking you questions would frankly she
did too and so did the narrow De Niro's
well yeah got it and they were asking
you what Vincent just had this guy act
that their language like one particular
scene they called it Vig Sato Marty what
are you saying Vic I said we call it
juice you know money you know he's
collecting just this juice and then they
were saying something about they call
him I call it merchandise stole a swag
he says something about swag animal vets
what swag he says stolen stuff stolen
property as we call it merch short for
merchandise so I changed a lot of scenes
the language not her scene Frank Vincent
said you jerk-off you said to somebody
and so Marty we never used that term we
say jagoff just like it said Jagga so
Frank Vincent has changes scene Iran is
the drug I was especially Bob how was
Pesci was she was all right I got along
with Pesci yeah did anybody on the
sudden you didn't get along with I love
whatever yes sir so it's a good
experience for you well I never was
gonna become a director or anything you
know sure
hi I thought maybe one day to remove II
never became bad and I was very close
with Nic pledgee very close though he's
a good friend that my neck so you know
when you look at the history of it you
got Frank Costello Lucky Luciano you got
Meyer Lansky and you
Bugsy and I know you and I were talking
briefly about Meyer Lansky who was how
was Meyer Lansky viewed in this whole
thing you know you watch Bugsy and you
kind of who he was or you watch the
movie mobsters with him and he's playing
this role and Meyer low-key but he made
a few hundred million dollars how did
you guys view Meyer Lansky how do we
view him as Chicago because it wasn't a
few to me as a Jew debt as a Jew that
had a lot of connections and he made a
lot of money Frisch Chicago Outfit and
the New York in the Chicago Outfit oh
well that's the way I viewed it that's
why I thought about it whether he did or
he then I didn't know but that's the way
I thought about him and uh honey I gave
this this guy a lot of respect over that
you know so there was a lot of respect
in the was he feud guy was he respected
guy was he a feared guy I never was a
feared or was he respect respect it him
God Frank who were the ones that were
feared names that were for you because
it's a big difference that were feared
names that were feared names where you
say you know this person was fear like
you take Sammy there you know you talk
about the the madman he was feared you
talk to families to find maybe a Larry
Newman was a little bit off and he was
it was a bit fear who else was the fewer
person and it was a lot of guys Angela
Petry Chuckie Nicoletti what's his name
I got that there's so many names I'm
losing their names young kind of field
you know kind of yeah he didn't fear a
guy like Tony Accardo because you know
he would give the direction Joey I you
people would give the directions Rica
would give the directions and it's and
stuff like that this is why Frankie
Calabrese they came along
Frankie Calabria no Frankie Calabrese
when he was nobody nobody believe me
when I tell ya and he was feared yeah
Frankie come to me and wanted to give me
alpha he went him he wanted me to excuse
me he wanted me to hook him up with the
outfit and I told Tony and Tony says I
do it the guy Frankie was a machine he
worked for your Union then and then
Frankie became a fair dead man and there
was a hairy element there was Butchie
Petrocelli there was James Thoreau Rallo
I could go on and on that's a list ahead
there's a reputation of these guys that
were feared they were maybe there were
not the biggest earners but they were
feared industry there was some of them
were very big earners or that's me yeah
and Heather's got it
so you're following up with Tony I mean
when you read about it you guys are best
friends for a long time you guys been
for instance you were in Chicago running
the streets and you're doing the you
know since 12 years old so when you read
about it you see the story when the FBI
came and you guys were kind of going
through it and you're not saying
anything you're not talking to the FBI
agents you're not saying anything to him
and you heard the recording you know
what was it on the recording you heard
could that kind of throw you off and
what you're saying off yeah I was I got
locked up and I just first day I got
locked up I was in the county jail at
Eric Clark Clark County Jail and I
received the visits from an agent and he
said we got information that there's a
contract out on your life
and I told to get the [ __ ] out of the
room
I knew it at games they play so when he
got to the door it's as if we could show
you positive proof that there's a
contract enter in your life would you
cooperate I said I can't tell you that
so I walked out of the room this
conference room and they brought me down
to I was I was in that dama Torre and
they brought me to his cell as why he
put me in his cell and he said because
there's a contract out on you this is
the Clark County jailer so I went in
just before I went in the cell they
called me back out and they said they
want to see a back upstairs again I said
I want to go out they says you got those
I went up and when I went up there was a
couple agents there I don't remember
their names they had these real the real
recordings and the air phones and they
had transcript
and he told me if you don't mind
listening to it and tell me who you
who's thought this talking at him say
listened then he interrupted me so who
was the voices I say can't tell you
right now I want to see I want to hear
old thing that's when I heard the voices
and it was too familiar voices and the
one guy said what's going on out there
he called him D sharp for Tony he says
it's not me it's the other guy at then
I'm listening the other guy he's got to
be referring to me I'm thinking he's
like a loose cannon he's in the can
right now
they locked them up I can't control him
he should be making too bad pretty soon
he says he's the one that's doing all of
that and he says yes he's then clean
your dirty laundry no I didn't fall out
of a tree I've heard that term used too
many times so I put the earphones down I
said I want to go back to the cell he
says do you know the voices I said yeah
I know the voices he wanted Tony is not
at this thing are you ready to cooperate
ace and that at this time I need to
think about it like me and myself I
can't the played it several things to do
it myself physically then I says if I do
that e1 mean anymore like suicide
suicide I've absolutely because I never
was brought up that way to roll to be
not an informant there's a big
difference between being an informant
and a witness I never was brought up
that way to testify and it rolled when
you use that word that's like snitching
is the same thing exactly got it guy
wasn't raised this way so I says that I
can't do that I says that first of all I
don't have the guts to kill myself
second of all if I did it
Tony winds up a winner it's mean it's
Plateau so I I waited till morning in
the morning a
ask the guard could I make a phone call
he said what do you need ice I needed to
talk that I'm agents that we're air he
says we'll give right back there within
30 seconds the door opened I said Jesus
Christ I thought maybe the agents were
sleeping in the room upstairs well
that's that fast they were there and I
told him you know I'll cooperate they
instantly moved me out of that gel put
me in a motel I had harboured guards
everywhere you could possibly think of
and then they he started interviewing me
the one game and he wanted me to talk
about murders and I didn't want them
they want you to talk about murders
first the Shah sincere you are about
being a witness you know and I said I'd
this is something I've never done before
I says this is our hard thing for you
you're asking me to do ice I can't do it
right now as I talked about other crimes
then at the very end he says you got to
talk about murders he says then you'll
get your immunity I said but he says we
didn't read your rights if we were edgy
your rights and you talked about murders
then we got you we can all you throw it
but as long as we didn't read you your
rights we can't all your thought that's
something though I never know that sorry
to take a chance what was I gonna do so
I took a chance as soon as I said that
he got up walked out the room he's
another guy be talking yet as I walked
into a [ __ ] trap that's the first
thing in in my mind because I can't
trust these guys all my life for chasing
me around trying to kill me put me in
jail all of a sudden I said the bomber
not a guy come in the room talk to me
and I was with friends with this guy to
Liz they the agent then assembly his
name is your friend with them till till
is they really how do conversations why
she begins everything how would you talk
when you're talking with the
conversation we're friends we talk about
everyday affairs mister we're friends
interesting I build up a trust than me
and
trust in him get out of here I'm serious
you FBI agent he's retired Wow several
of them and several Metro cops enters
then our friends we are to this day the
guys same guys they used to chase me
wrong trying to kill me
weird looked at in a different it was a
ball game we played it was a ball game
they just had more people in their game
than us yeah that makes sense
Frank what did it do to you with your a
relationship with Tony like how did you
view this friendship now of nearly 30
something years 40 something destroyed
me yeah it destroyed me that a friend
would do this to me my best friend mmm I
love this guy like my brother for him to
put cast all the weight on me what was
devastating you know I never thought
he'd do that but he had to take the heat
off him
because he was doing wrong you see he
got paid back in the end right yeah of
course I miss the means I could go back
to Chicago tomorrow and live there you
could go back in about yeah no one would
do anything to you bet I could really
they know they knew back there they know
a lot of guys back there said why would
Frankie rolled there has to be a reason
would cause them to do this he would
never do that and I would never do that
once he got the head was there
validation where your credibility went
up my credibility
with who which sacado outfit look
because they're not I would never go
back there and try to be a gangster no
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is so you're doing what you're
doing you go on your roll man the right
ability as far as what I thought yeah
meaning so who's really the one so maybe
it was Tony maybe it was you how did
Chicago view you and Tony first of all
they didn't approve of me Roland which
they never would of course they would
yeah they never would approve of it and
I don't blame him I'm sure they wouldn't
kill me if I went back there yeah they
know I had to do what I'd done we're not
gonna sit down and have past and share
pasta together I don't have no fear of
my life absolutely none
of going back there at one time I did at
fair at what point did that field go
away took 23 or 25 years also the fears
of recent like two decades that has gone
well you dick you know when I went in it
was yeah I've been 34 years got it
so 25 years got it when I first put my
first book got that's when I opened up
the door what the day Tony died what was
your immediate reaction what will called
you like how what happened to you when
they I was called prior to him being
found so you knew this was gonna take
player and and the news I was in the
witness protection program and Mobile
Alabama
oh no but did you know that this event
was coming or no you heard a date-date
hey I heard I get a full like I heard it
on TV that the splatter brothers were
missing I said well I said well they're
dead I thought to myself then I get a
call from the Marshal Service and a
marshal service says to me the FBI want
to speak to you so I go talk to them FBI
they come over talk on a dating come
over we talked on the phone that same
guy aroldi friend yeah agent he says
Tony and Michael didn't show up for
court do you know where they would have
ran off go I said they didn't run
anywhere he said you know that it's
because ain't no Tony
I says if I if I was a guess I'm a
knight a turd that right now
how do you know that it's because they
know Tony ain't gonna run I said I know
it
Tony knows that you're gonna get caught
sooner or later I've been around this
guy on my life Dennis I know he's not
gonna run he says really I said yeah
you'll see four days later the body
showed up in a guard field he said where
do you think they were killed afterwards
as they were killing off Carville he's
worried I says probably in a basement
some house where I says either it's
Cicero Illinois
or Bensenville why do you say that
because we got people that live in them
towns and you could lose stuff in their
houses that was that interesting years
later would Sammy the bull when that
happened would Sammy how did you view
Sammy I figured the guy had to do what
he had to do I figured god he's got him
got each room to the Wolves similar
story
yeah similar slurry yeah I never
disrespect the Sammy I always felt as
though Sammy was a man like me I
consider myself a man is Sammy a man did
you guys ever speak or no huh did you
ever have ever speak or no us Tommy okay
I got it
you know Sammy's got his own private
life I know he did 20 years the other
guy you know but that's how do you get
involved in drugs
you know I don't know what the story is
there final thoughts before we go into
the books here what what is the you know
conclusion you got from living that life
obviously it's a whole different story
today where a lotta that doesn't exist
when you said you had a moment two years
after you were you know you you rolled
what happened to me you're like you know
what this is not a life I want to live I
want to live a change life what would
what would those events what was that
process like well you know you're around
legitimate people and you see how they
live and you know even legitimate people
have a bad sight on you know and I start
going to church and stuff like that I
always I was raised the Catholic I went
to Catholic school as a young young man
so I went back to the religion and then
I stopped going to church and I just
know that there is a guide unto Jesus
you know and I do my praying that's all
hopefully is he's accepted me hopefully
interesting very interesting well you
know your story's a very very
interesting story and there's a lot of
different lessons in there you know I'm
always curious different about the
Chicago versus New York and what
cultures
they have on the leadership style but
here's what I would say if you're
watching this obviously you've seen on
vitami we've done a lot of different mob
interviews whether it's Michael Franzese
Gianni Russo Oscar Goodman I mean I can
go on with a lot of different lists that
we have and there's a lot of exposure
that we accidentally got into this
market if you'd like to know more about
his story he wrote a book called the
rise and fall of a casino mobster we'll
put the link below here but if you ever
pay a visit to well Vegas you do
personal tours apparently maybe tell us
a little bit this personal tour so what
is personal tour yeah I put people in my
personal vehicle or I take them in a
rented vehicle and I bring up to all the
locations in Las Vegas there we shot the
movie Casino the movie and places where
people were murdered robberies and it's
personal I'm in the car with my people
you tell the story about white fellows
everything interests and if they ever go
to TripAdvisor and stuff like that they
get my phone number you know yeah we got
to put the link to TripAdvisor and by
the way even the mob museum do you take
them to the dome are museums I know your
pictures on the wall at the mob museum
as well did they go through that tour
with you or no do you go there I don't I
do speaking engagements yeah they call
me quite off okay god I do speaking
engagements there so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna put the link below we're
also gonna put his phone number below to
find out about the tours and if you
again want to find out more go to his
book the link will be below for the book
Frank thank you so much for coming I
really enjoy talking you truly